just because you get a storm and you're  waiting on one thing the world keeps  spinning and working I got an oil change  due on the generator got some feeling to  do you know all your general chores  first thing I do is loosen up my nut for  the oil pan there  whenever you're putting a filter on you  want a nice clean tight fit change my  filter I'm not interested in how the  rest of the world does it so I do it  like they do I'm interested in doing it  in a way that is best for the equipment  that I understand next thing I got to do  is refill it the oil level looks good my  filter is on tight my nut at the bottom  is on tight the cap is back on time to  turn around so you just hope he'll kick  over  it's warning sounds good looks good back  to giving the weather report and single  rat with plans  you